we turn now to actor and best-selling
author Holly Robinson Pete she's also a
dedicated mom dedicated to changing the
world for her son Rodney Peete Jr Roddy
was diagnosed with autism spectrum
disorder when he was three Holly really
struggled with the diagnosis at first
before becoming an activist and advocate
for families like hers through the
hollyrod foundation Holly and her son
who is now 24 years old are telling
their story in a brand new book Charlie
makes a splash is about a young man with
autism discovering his love for being
around water they write when you're a
kid like me you see the world in special
ways and making a splash sets me free
please welcome here Holly Robinson Pete
good to see you good to be seen how are
you doing good happy labor day so does
he love to swim how did this come about
this kid loves to swim so much so when
RJ was three years old he was diagnosed
with autism we call that the never day
why because we heard all these things he
would never do one of them was you know
uh have meaningful employment have
friends say I love you all those things
and you know that's hard for parents to
hear but the one thing he could do when
he was three was swim better than anyone
else so in his swim class he wasn't
verbal he wasn't able to really read the
social cues and connect with the other
kids but that little boy was a fish and
he felt so good in the water
what is the relationship for people
children on the Spectrum with water I
don't know I don't know but some
children certainly mind gravitate
towards water he gravitates towards
water he loves water he loves to Splash
he loves the feeling of watering around
him it makes him feel better since
sorely and so and and also we do hear a
lot about kids with autism you know
drowning quite honestly and that's
because a lot of them are driven they
love the water they kind of gravitate to
it and so my brother Charlie which was
the original book and this is the
companion piece Charlie makes a splash
has a lot of back matter in the back of
the book talking about how important it
is to teach children all children but
certainly children with autism how to
swim you know it's it's funny uh well
not funny it's ironic that you're here
because my daughter was telling me that
there is a child in her class who has
autism yeah and it was one of those
moments where I stopped and realized I
don't quite know
how to explain this yes how do you
explain it well one of the reasons why
we wanted to write this book is because
when my kids were in middle or actually
Elementary School they didn't have a
book there was no book and I went to
Scholastic and I said you guys like
autism is so prevalent yet there's no
book to really explain it to elementary
school kids so that's why we wrote my
brother Charlie along with my daughter
and then this time Charlie makes a
splash along with RJ because often
you'll hear about people with Autism and
you'll hear parents or siblings talking
about them but we wanted RJ to be the
author so he could speak for himself and
self-advocate so I think my brother
Charlie and Charlie makes a splash are
great books to explain to children that
autism is a disorder and it kind of
affects impacts the way people relate
and socialize but the more we know early
on I think the less judgment and more
compassion we
we are able to cultivate with children
and he's now been working for the
Dodgers yeah so one of the things they
said he would never do was have
meaningful employment and now the kid
you know 20 years later has a World
Series ring with the Dodgers
um my favorite team they're doing quite
well right now the good news is he's a
clubhouse attendant with them and you
know they presented him with the ring
and it was a real moment a full circle
moment so I'm always thankful to the
Dodgers for hiring inclusively Holly do
you find that him for example having
that job and and really having to
socialize yeah does that continue to
help him get better at Social Life yes
he has purpose he has a sense of
belonging he has friends yeah kids that
didn't have friends most of his life
growing up so he has all these big
baseball players that are always looking
out for him and that's amazing right
that's such a great thing it's something
he didn't have I remember when you
started talking about autism when you
first thought about your husband was
like nope ain't doing that no not
talking about that and you did and what
happened to you when you went to well
you know I win every argument at home
boom just do as wives do let's just do
that's why we're married 28 years no
um because he couldn't see the bigger
picture of he didn't want his kid to be
the poster child for autism he was in
denial a lot of a lot of dads really
have a really struggle with this
diagnosis
um and so yeah so I stepped in and said
we can help people we can advocate for
folks I have a big mouth let's use it
for good but at Disney what happened to
you we went to Disney World and we went
and met a family a family came up to us
and said thank you for advocating both
of my daughters are on the Spectrum and
RJ was so sweet he was like Mom what did
they want why did they thank me and I
said because you advocated shared your
story and it helped them and so he said
does that make me a hero I was like well
yeah kind of does but then later on you
know I found like a Halo of pizza under
his bed I was like what is that I'm
fussing him he's like I have autism it
makes me a hero oh what's wrong with the
pizza so it's something that you know
autism is something that we all should
understand more and be compassionate
about and Charlie makes us is something
it's a book I'm so proud of especially
with him being a published author Holly
Robinson Pete thanks for joining us this
morning thank you thanks for the time
Holly's new book Charlie makes a splash
is available tomorrow